-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
It is time to play
Egg Roulette,
but I'm gonna need some help.
Her new documentary,
"Selena Gomez: My Mind and Me,"
is available now
on Apple TV Plus.
Please welcome Selena Gomez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for coming.
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-Yes, James.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-In my hand,
I have one dozen eggs.
-Ohh.
-Oh, God.
-Eight of them
have been hard-boiled,
and four of them are still raw.
You and Selena
will take turns selecting
one egg at a time,
smashing it upon your head.
[ Laughter ]
You won't know which eggs
are hard-boiled or raw!
Once you choose an egg, you must
smash that egg upon your head.
-Okay.
-No put backs.
-No put backs. Gotcha.
-First one to smash two eggs
upon their head loses.
Selena, would you choose
the first egg?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Be careful! Be careful!
-Stop it. You make me mad.
This is the things
you make me do?
-Good luck!
-How does it feel?
Do you feel confident?
-I don't -- I don't know.
-Okay.
-Ohh!
-Ohh! You're lucky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-James!
No!
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Ooh!
You can do it.
-I don't have a good feeling
about this one.
-Go!
-Can I --
-No! Do it!
♪♪
[ Selena laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ohh!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I knew it. I knew it.
I knew it!
-Yep.
-Gosh.
Good luck.
-Aah! [ Laughs ] Okay.
Oh, I don't feel good
about this one either. Aah!
-You don't?
-Why did I agree to this?!
-I'm so happy you came on.
-Okay, okay.
Do you have an event tonight
after the show?
-No.
-Oh, perfect.
-Oh, God. Aah!
-Oh, my God.
-Aah! Aah! What the --
-That was the nicest crack.
You just did a little --
-Sorry, sorry.
-You just did a little cracking.
Look at that.
Now you have, like,
an Elvis spit curl.
-Great.
This is so -- so sexy.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh, this is good.
It's a tie game.
-Tie game. 1-1.
-But that one's suspicious.
-Aah.
Oh, no. You -- Ohh.
Yeah.
-♪ Ba da-da da-da, da da-da ♪
-Do it!
-♪ Ha la-la da-da ♪
Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-I'll do a good one this time.
-♪ Da da-da da-da,
mm-mm, deh-deh ♪
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Oh, I don't feel good
about this one either.
-This is for the win!
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
I did that for you!
-You did that for me.
Thank you so much.
Selena Gomez! The greatest!
We love having you on the show!
-I love you!
-We're talking to Selena
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!
Selena Gomez!
-Aah!